hi everyone my name is Sally I'm here at
Q con Barcelona and this morning I gave
a keynote about kubernetes storage my
talk was about debunking the myth that
kubernetes storage is hard one of the
biggest challenges that we have with
storage in general is that really it is
complicated but the beauty of kubernetes
is that it introduces abstraction layers
and when we have these abstraction
layers we can take a very big
complicated problem and break it into
smaller pieces so with kubernetes
storage what we're able to do is treat
storage as four different problems one
you have to figure out what storage you
want to use two you have to figure out
how to deploy that Storage three you
have to figure out how to integrate that
deployed storage with your kubernetes
cluster four you have to figure out how
your containerized workload is going to
consume the deployed storage so to sum
things up storage is complicated but the
reality is that the way we deal with
complicated problems is by breaking them
into smaller pieces and what kubernetes
allows you to do is finally treat
storage as smaller subproblems that you
can handle independently and that
simplifies the overall process of
deploying stateful workloads on
kubernetes so for the full talk take a
look at the description below and stay
tuned for more cute con content
[Music]